من المتوقع ان الموثوق مستحضرات التجميل
العالمي من نحو 398 مليار دولار في 2020
الى 665 مليار دولار بحلول الفين وثلاثين
مستحضرات العنايه بالبشره تتصدر مبيعات
التجميل العالميه منذ الرائحه وفي 2021
كانت مسؤوله عن حوالي 41% من حجم سوق
التجميل العالمي السوق الاسيويه مسؤول عما
يقرب من 35% من السوق العالميه لمستحضرات
العنايه بالبشره وفي عام 2016 من المتوقع
ان تبلغ ارادتها حول العالم نحو 188 مليار
دولار لوريال الفرنسيه هي الشركه الرائده
في مستحضرات التجميل حول العالم خلال 2022
حققت مبيعات تقدر بثمانيه وثلاثين.26
مليار دولار اخيرا الولايات المتحده
مسؤوله عن معظم ايرادات مستحضرات تجميل
العالميه بشكل عام وبحسب من المقرر ان
تتجاوز المبيعات داخل البلاد حجز 91 مليار
دولار خلال 2023